lore the cultural capital of
Pakistan Punjab is the most populous
Province and it said whoever wins here
stands the best chance of winning the
country it's considered a stronghold for
noas Sharif and his party the Pakistan
Muslim League he held a campaign rally
in
guala I support him because whatever he
has promised he has delivered whatever
he says he
does if anyone has helped the poor it's
Noel Sharif he built a Motorway anything
good that happened in this country
happened during his tenure carefully
shot campaign footage zoomed in on the
crowds and gave the image of a packed
Stadium but turnout was low the stadium
was not filled and the mood was subdued
Sharif has been cleared by the courts
despite being convicted on corruption
charges sentenced to prison and
disqualified from holding public office
for life now he's back and is considered
by some to be the top contender in this
election but if he is a favorite it's
because the most popular politician in
Pakistan is in jail for what his
supporters believe are charges
orchestrated to keep Imran Khan and his
PTI party from seriously contesting
these elections no prime minister in the
country's more than 75e history has ever
completed a full term in office it's the
military support that is seen as making
or breaking governments here Khan's
party is facing what many consider is a
military back Crackdown although the
military denies accusations of influence
saying it's apolitical on the streets
many people tend to
disagree is the military that does
everything whoever they want will come
into office they have decided to make
the Muslim League win the elections will
not be fair but I will vote for the
PTI we are walked for Khan and the PTI
what has happened to him is wrong they
removed his Cricket back symbol from the
ballot paper then stopped him from
standing the youth will vote for him I
think we live in a Democratic Society
but we were not
Democratic we're living in a
dictatorship
Society campaigning has been quieter
than previous elections and in some
cases PTI supporters have been forced to
campaign in
secret but people will have their say at
The Ballot Box and despite all the
challenges and obstacles Imran Khan's
party forced to stand Us Independence
May yet hold the balance of power Assad
bag Al jaaz Lor
Pakistan make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer